hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast improving diagnostic testing
and interpretation of chronic kidney
disease presented by dr. Kevin Martin
and dr. Stewart Sprague we are excited
to bring you this educational web
seminar presented by land brutes and
sponsored by siemens healthcare siemens
Healthcare is one of the world's largest
suppliers of medical infrastructure and
is a leader in medical imaging
laboratory diagnostics and clinical IP
for more information please visit www m
/ healthcare I am Brendan Kelly Kim of
labyrinth and I'll be your moderator for
today's event before we begin I'd like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting questions
whenever you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have signed for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in a
slide window to enlarge the slide window
just click on a screen icon located in
the lower right finally if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation we want to know about it
click on the support button at the top
right of the presentation window or use
the Q&A button to let us know you're
having a problem this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits I'd now
like to introduce the first of our
speakers dr. kevin martin dr. martin is
the director of the division of
nephrology at st. louis university and
professor of internal medicine he has
served as chairman of the general
medicine V study section of the National
Institutes of Health dr. martens
clinical research interests include
parathyroid hormone vitamin d metabolism
and secondary hyperthyroidism he has
authored 230 publications and
professional journals including the New
England Journal of Medicine kidney
international and the
american journal of kidney disease
clinical journal of the american society
of nephrology we also have dr. stewart
sprayed with us today for this webinar
dr. Sprague is chief of the division of
Nephrology and hypertension and director
of nephrology research at northshore
university health system new clinical
professor of medicine at the University
of Chicago Pritzker School of Medicine
Chicago Illinois his clinical focus
includes chronic kidney disease end
stage renal failure osteoporosis in
chronic kidney disease chronic kidney
disease mineral and bone disease and
hyperparathyroidism please join me in
welcoming both doctors Martin and
doctors break I will now turn the
presentation over to dr. Martin to start
thank you and hello to everybody I'm
going to spend this part of the
presentation to talk about clinical
chemistry assays that are used in
patients with chronic kidney disease and
spend most of the time talking about
parathyroid hormone and vitamin D which
continued to be at the most problematic
so in a general way the clinical
chemistry requirements for following
patients with chronic kidney disease are
many and varied involved a little bit
over time you can see that of course the
measurement of creatinine and estimates
of GFR are important to stage the kidney
disease and and these continue to be as
the mainstream of assessing progression
and other markers are up-and-coming and
such as his statin see for example was
probably not in the mainstream at this
point in time and the formula for
estimating the GFR may also undergo
evolution we currently use mdrd formula
and this may gradually morph to a
different equation CKD epi which may be
a little more accurate higher
levels of GFR but for the moment I think
creatinine and egfr by the mdrd formula
are in the mainstream head the lab also
needs to be able to measure a protein in
the urine or microbe human had to be
able to perform accurate your analysis
for identification of cells in the
sediment they need to be able to
evaluate lipids and blood and glucose
uric acid is important as well as
general and hematology and clearly have
frequent requirements for measurements
of be UN creer creatinine and the other
electrolytes and we also have a need for
measurements of serum albumin and
24-hour urine either urea or sodium and
there's necessity for iron panels and of
course the antigens and antibodies for
hepatitis B and C but we're going to add
to focus on most today it is his last 17
here of calcium phosphate house and
phosphatase and spend most of the time
talking about parathyroid hormone and
vitamin D so let me begin by talking
about PTH assays so just as a refresher
we can see here in the diagram that
parathyroid hormone is an 84 amino acid
peptide and this main function is to
regulate the concentration of calcium in
serum if there is kidney function
presence as varies throughout most of
chronic kidney disease parathyroid
hormone also increases phosphate
excretion in the urine and so lowers the
concentration of phosphate in blood the
the biologic activity of parathyroid
hormone is contained within the first 30
for 30 or so amino acids and the first
few amino acids here are highly critical
for any biologic activity and the
remainder of the hormone is not believed
to have any significant biologic
activity at this point in time so by way
of history you can see that
p th has assays have been around since
the 1960s where it was really done by
radioimmunoassay and this was a tidbit
of things to come and problems with p th
essays and initially the antibodies are
directed towards the c-terminal region
of the PTH molecule here and they didn't
perform very well as the as the issue
kind of evolved and so the next step was
to try to find different antibodies and
turned out that have phase antibodies
with deterrence in the middle part of
the molecule were somewhat better and
seem to behave well clinically however
that seems that odds with the idea that
the biologic activity was in the
n-terminal 30 peptides or so and of
course assays were introduced that would
be directed towards this portion of the
molecule but suffered from lack of
sensitivity and and it reproducibility
and and really were not satisfactory so
the major breakthrough in pth assays
came and just at the beginning of the
90s where the first of the two side
antibodies was introduced by believing
that this would have capture PTH from
serum with the usually with the
c-terminal and buddy and then detected
with an n-terminal a say this was
believed to measure only the intact
peptide and so currently go by the name
of intact pth essays as i'll show you
they measure more than just the intact
pth peptide itself and then the most
recent development is to try to develop
antibodies which were with the detection
antibody very near the n-terminus right
within the first four amino acids the so
called a second-generation amino metric
assays and we should really reflect more
of the biologic activity that were
interested in trying to quantify and
measure but the problem with PTH essays
is really because of this that is not
only PTH the one
for peptide circulates in plasma but
there's also a variety of truncated PTH
peptides that also circulate and these
are a very from from the region of their
specific n terminus and I'll say a
little bit more about that later but if
they continued to cause problems in the
assay to be sure you don't have cross
reactivity with these other fragments
which may not have biologic activity so
of course it was of interest to find out
where these fragments came from and we
we know that them the PTH is synthesized
and stored within the parathyroid in
these secret ory granules and then with
a stimulus of calcium falling in the
blood the stimulus to secrete the
hormone which it does and secretes the
intact 12 84 peptide into the
circulation and if the calcium is high
and there's no need for PTH secretion a
degradation pathway is triggered within
the parathyroid cell which begins to
produce these part of high Royd
fragments devoid of biologic activity
within the cell and then these can be
under certain circumstances and secreted
into the circulation so that again to
emphasize that in the circulation at any
one time you have a mixture of fragments
of PTH as well as the intact 12 84 amino
acid peptide and just by way of
historical example and this was from
direct cannulation of parathyroid glands
in cattle sampling the blood draining
the parathyroid and fractionating
immunoreactivity according to molecular
size and you can see that in the middle
panel here there's approximately equal
proportions of intact pth which is at
the arrow there and lower molecular
weight c-terminal fragments if calcium
is low and in the left-hand panel
there's a much more intact pth than
fragment and
conversely a serum calcium is high
there's very little impact PTH and all
of that pth peptides that are secreted
from the gland are actually inactive
fragments so the fragments can be
generated in the parathyroid and can be
secreted under certain circumstances but
to complicate the issue had these
fragments can also appear in the
peripheral circulation as shown in this
experiment here where an injection of
intact pth is given add to an
experimental animal and you can see in
the green line there's a gradual
appearance of PTH fragments and that
accumulates over time so the bottom line
of this is that pth fragments can
complicate the the essay they come from
the parathyroid gland and from
peripheral metabolism of the peptide and
so it caused challenges and how to get a
valid index of parathyroid activity in
serum and so over the years then there's
been several to side assays that have
been developed for this purpose and most
capture PTH by a c-terminal antibody and
use varying detection antibodies to to
some region within the first 30 or so
amino acids and and as I mentioned to
you because of this one labeled at 72 84
which is actually a family of PTH
fragments if this is detected by your
essay then it can cause significant
problems as we get to in a minute so to
try and avoid that I have mentioned
these newer assays with the detection
antibody directed right at the very end
terminals which should at least
theoretically give you the most reliable
index of biologically active pth in
serum so the the why this becomes
important is illustrated in this slide
here which gives a hypothetical example
do you certainly can validate this in
vivo if just for a moment consider that
we have an intact pth value of 500 this
could represent 250 at picograms of pth
one day before the active peptide and an
equal quantity of the biologically
inactive 784 or with a total pph of 500
could represent 100 of pth 154 and 400
of 72 84 or as Sonnen depend the sea
column it could represent 400 of intact
pth and only 100 of the pth fragment so
all of these will give you a total PTH
value of 500 if the PT HSA also detects
and the PT 874 family and indeed and
that happens quite a bit and then the
complication occurs in patients with
kidney disease because unlike the
situation in the normal patient where
there's a relatively low amount of this
PTH 784 family shown here in the yellow
slice of pie in in chronic kidney
disease where all these fragments
accumulate and the proportion of the 784
fragment to intact pth can become
approximately equal although those great
variation on either side of this so you
can see here the difficulty of trying to
measure biologically active pph the red
slice of the pie in the whole sea of PTH
fragments and requires a detailed
knowledge of the specificity of the
antibodies used in the assay and in
order to obtain a meaningful result so
again just illustrated in a different
way we have many PTH peptides in the
circulation we're trying to measure
these with a capture and various
detector antibodies and detect the site
of action of the detection antibody is
really critical to what might be
measured for anything that measures from
seven on is likely to measure some of
the 784 family and perhaps as I
mentioned to you more specificity can
potentially be gained by assays that are
directed with the detection antibody
right at the very end terminus so you
can see in this complicated a sea of
events can cause tremendous confusion on
a clinical level so here are various
commercial pth assays that are available
and it gives you an idea of the between
method differences in concentration of
parathyroid hormone that you might get
in it in a single PTH sample so they
range here from 54 in this particular
assay shown at the top to the value of a
hundred and eighty-three has seen here
in another assay and so all of these
assays going by supposedly intact pth
assays and they're supposed to measure
just the 12 84 but an actual fact the
significant detection of the seventh 84
PTH peptides so you can see that this
there's a greater than threefold range
in PTH assays and you can begin to
imagine how difficult it's going to be
then to try to get a meaningful
comparison between between labs and
we're going to talk about this in terms
of practice guidelines in a minute so
this variation to a large degree is
related to the ability of the assay to
measure and detect these 784 family of
peptides that I mentioned to you and I
think it's clear from the slide here
that the ability of the various
commercial PTH essays to detect this
family of peptides very large but most
assays detected to some extent except
the ones on there on the bottom which
have a detection antibody at the very
end terminus of the PTH molecule so with
this a great variation in mind you can
see how difficult it is to make clinical
practice guidelines and for this issue
of progressive hyperparathyroidism in
chronic kidney disease there's been two
attempts to try to make clinical
practice guidelines the one I'm showing
you here is one known as que digo
practice guidelines and sponsored by the
National Kidney Foundation but now a
worldwide effort
and they have come with the refinement
really of the various practice
guidelines and that have been around so
the two sets of guidelines that exist
are the so-called k dokey guidelines on
the left and que digo guidelines on the
right so the que diga ones are older and
recommended a target value for an intact
pth assays and patients on dialysis to
be in the 150 to 300 range with calcium
in the normal range phosphorus from
normal to slightly high and to consider
a calcium phosphate product of less than
55 so these were the best available data
at the time but the assays that gave
rise to this suggested range I really
don't exist anymore and and so they this
was based on fairly weak data and an
assay that can't be verified under
modern therapeutic regimens so the que
digo guidelines on the right were an
effort to refine these targets and
taking into account the variation in
detection of the various assets that
I've described I tried to suggest that
maybe should be best is to factor this
by the upper limit of the normal range
and suggest as a reasonable range in
patients with chronic kidney disease and
dialysis to be somewhere between two to
nine times the upper limit of normal and
i'll come back to talk about this again
in a minute like the initial guidelines
on calcium values in the normal range
and suggested maybe that we can do a
little bit better with phosphorus
control and try and get it more towards
the normal range which would be
approximately 3.5 to 4.5 in most air
clinical chemistry labs so a little more
stringent control of phosphate is
desirable so the trouble with these had
the variation in the assay is that em if
you try to adhere by the que digo
guidelines and the details
of this light another important
specifically except to say that
depending on the particular apps they
used it will lead to differences in
classifications as the patient as
whether the patient is within the
guideline or without or without at the
guideline so it becomes an important
issue to try to help those ordering PTH
essays and to interpret the result and
to try to have them categorize at the
patient appropriately so to summarize
this the target pth range and
recommended in k dokey was this 150 to
300 have based on studies that that
during the early 90s with the PT HSA
that we know is no longer available to
us and so more recent studies with the
different PTH assays that are available
have confirmed that pth levels are
associated with a bone turnover with
cardiovascular disease and mortality and
and the range stratification for risk
has been defined further and knowing
that there's an increase in mortality of
bths too low as well as the bath and
increase in mortality of pth is too high
and suggesting that we focus in more on
this range and and and try to use this
and to em and to correlate this with the
various SI is used so the big question
is then at these target ranges useful
regardless of the PT HSA and you can
imagine that by what I've told you so
far that the answer that that is
probably no and we need to solve the
problem better so what issue is could we
standardize PTH assays and in an assay
that detects these family of inactive
fragments the 70-80 for family with
varying degrees of efficiency makes the
the goal of standardizing PTH essays are
almost impossible so should we try to
apply correction factors and try to get
everybody more or less within the same
ballpark of this and that may be helpful
and or should we just try to had to find
the targets that are specific for a
given a say and that would require that
the clinical labs report which a say
they're using em and as you know that's
not always had done all those will say
towards the end that that's a particular
goal of some of their and the froggy
societies so it was to try to get around
this that the practice guideline group
tried to factor this in terms of upper
limit of normal and suggesting that in
the range of two to nine times the upper
limit of normal may cover most assays
and and maybe be give rise to values
that are within had the desired target
so if you're going to factor things by
reference value and they're your normal
rain so to speak then you need to pay
attention to hell you get the normal
range and what are the criteria used
whether was it a rigorous population or
one that was just convenient so we
really need to exclude the things that
we know regulate PTH are associated with
changes in concentration so we need to
know that the patients for the normal
range reference value determinations are
not hypocalcemic another hypercalcemia
have relatively normal kidney function
and not taking medications that can
interfere with calcium control a vitamin
d metabolism and don't have any disease
of calcium and metabolism Stevens such
as hypercalciuria and they're taking a
reasonably normal intake and nowadays we
have to pay attention to their vitamin D
status or should we make sure that are
not with low levels of vitamin D which
is the potential to increase pt8 so just
to illustrate this in these studies by
cavalia another's here's a comparison
between manufacturers reference ranges
and a reference range found by
evaluating colleagues
in a carefully defined population as
such that I've described and you can see
that you start here on the bottom it
makes quite a bit of difference in this
essay the manufacturers reference ranges
12 288 whereas with the had the Cavalli
a normals was 10 247 so some of these
values are dramatically different some
not so dramatic but as you begin to
multiply these by factors of the upper
limit of normal you can see that
different ranges are going to result so
if we want to target this que digo
suggestion based on the manufacturers
reference values you can see for this
essay up here is would be say a hundred
and thirty six to six twelve but based
upon the other normal range is 132
almost and 600 not too bad but the this
last essay would have values up to costa
800 and what is the normal range is
different to be closer to 4 under so you
can see that it does make it make a
difference with take a difference with
some essays and and not so much with
others and it just calls attention to
the fact that we need had to pay
exquisite attention had to have the
normal range I was developed so to go
back into the guidelines and leave pdh
for example for a moment and we the
guidelines also to suggest that we need
to pay attention to the vitamin D status
and suggest that 25 hydroxy d levels
should be measured in these patients
since it's a well-known factor that
could affect parathyroid function so
it's neatly the lab needs to be able to
measure 25 hydroxy d and repeat testing
and would be required if there's any
therapeutic intervention and and the
initial stab was to suggest that we
should try to take these values and
treat it according to the
recommendations of the of the general
population so we know that that 25
hydroxy d is the metabolites that
measures the vitamin d status
and although there are slight
differences in the definition of vitamin
D deficiency and insufficiency depending
on the group for example the Institute
of Medicine suggests a range of normal
of above 20 nanograms per ml and on the
one hand while the endocrine society
would would say that that has to be
somewhat higher than that I would take
the lower limit of normal as 30 so have
in general I think most of the
nephrology community would think that
they were tried to get at least above
this 39 grams per ml value and we'll try
to institute and various therapies said
to try to achieve that goal so the
practice guidelines stayed here in
patients with CKD from three to five and
under houses at 2500 CD might be
measured and repeated determinations and
depending on the therapeutic
intervention will be required and they
suggest that vitamin D deficiency and
insufficiency be corrected using
treatment strategies mainly directed at
towards the osteo product population
this is a an area that's undergoing
revision constantly there's many
clinical trials to show this I know you
can't read the details here but it shows
you that was many had trials of avec
trying to correct early look at the
effects of vitamin D supplementation and
its variation among the trials but in
general and the studies to the left of
this vertical this M vertical line and
here and like see I guess I'm sorry the
get this vertical line here I can't seem
to highlight the line but let me get it
and that this shows that the suppression
of PTH when you achieve correction of
vitamin d insufficiency or deficiency
but a big controversy continues as the
weather had this is them meaningful and
and beneficial em add to the patients
and but in general there are some areas
that seem that to stick out here you can
see that them it does perhaps lower and
proteinuria in patients so this is an
important area that needs for the study
and we have also dated to say that this
might lower PTH and help with PTH
control and it seems to be seems to be
safe it affects various bone and mineral
and markers and the hesitancy is that it
may not and there's no solid data to
know that is influences and mortality in
these patients groups in these patient
groups but it may well be helpful in the
general selling a kidney disease by this
dead decrease in albuminuria and that I
mentioned on the last slide it may be
important for the progression of kidney
disease and and it may be important in
some other aspects of inflammation and
inflammatory markers etc so this is an
ongoing area that's where waiting and
more definitive their clinical trials as
we go forth as we go forward but so and
I think with but both for the vitamin D
assays as well as for the PTH essays it
was felt in the nephrology practice
guidelines committee that that we need
to be aware of the variation that can
occur and they recommended that the
clinical laboratories would begin to
inform the clinicians of the particular
assay method used and to report any
changes in methods or handling and that
that might occur so that the clinician
can have an I can have an idea that some
sa parameter has changed that there may
be differences in their ranges and
expectations so they can adjust their
clinical practice accordingly so far
this has not been widely implemented but
may may there may come more
recommendations
Sam as we go as we go forward and so in
conclusion I would say that that pth and
25-hydroxyvitamin D assays are currently
routine measurements and chronic kidney
disease the PTH assay continues to be
problematic with interim inter method
variability I mentioned the issue with
appropriate reference ranges and the
core sample handling and individual
variations there's a necessity to
measure various bone markers to
complement p th and currently the most
common one is alkaline phosphatase
there's a new markers on the horizon
such as fgf23 as Claire Austin perhaps
bone specific offense phosphatase or
maybe markers of osteoclast activity
that are currently being evaluated in
this area of the disturbances in bone
and mineral metabolism and CKD and have
not been incorporated into the routine
clinical laboratory assessment at the
present time but probably will be in the
not-too-distant future so with that I a
brief overview I'm going to stop at this
this time and hand you back there to the
moderator and thank you for your
attention thank you dr. Martin for
bringing that information to us for more
information on the topic of chronic
kidney disease we're now going to turn
to our other speaker today dr. Stuart
Sprague
good afternoon thank you i'm going to
try to follow up here from dr. Martin ah
and try to give you how we deal with
this clinically and taking care of
patients with chronic kidney disease I
would like to start first going over
some of the pathophysiology associated
with the development of chronic kidney
disease as we start to decrease or lose
our GFR we start having five state
retention not necessarily
hyperphosphatemia and with that passing
a retention we actually get a inhibition
of calcium or the ionized calcium tends
to drop we also get an inhibition of
calcitriol both from the increase in
phosphorus as well as it used to be
thought though these other factors that
play a role there in decreasing GFR but
the decrease in calcitriol the decrease
in ionized calcium and the increased
factors actually both help to increase
our the production and release of
parathyroid hormone in addition there
tends to be a resistance of the
skeletons parathyroid hormone where they
actually need a higher parathyroid
hormone concentration in order to
stimulate the bone remodeling and cycle
so this all leads to a hyper parathyroid
a bone disease in addition to what's
happening in terms of parathyroid
hormone we now know that we're
decreasing GFR and phosphate retention
we get increases in the faucet or
caramel and fibroblast growth factor 23
or fgf23 fgf23 is also a potent
inhibitor of calcitriol production by
inhibiting the one alpha hydroxylase in
addition calcif GF 23 does have some
effect in inhibiting parathyroid hormone
but at inhibitory effect on parathyroid
hormone is greatly overridden by the
stimulation of increased PTH by the
decreased calcitriol increased phosphate
and decreases in ionized calcium PTH
also goes and stimulates fgf
23 we also have the production of
another protein matrix extracellular
fascial glycoprotein which is induced by
fgf-23 and there's actually some
evidence that this mep e may actually
interfere with vaughn mineralization so
at the level of the skeleton we have the
effect of the high purify rate hormone
causing hyperparathyroidism as well as
other factors potentially mediated
through fgf23 an epi that may alter a
bone mineralization just touch slide
here just kind of goes over the hormonal
changes we see as chronic kidney disease
develops the first thing that actually
happens is noted by a line number one is
very early in the development of CKD we
get increases in tough GF 23 this is
followed again with GF ours that are
fairly normal and with decreases in your
calcitriol or 125 vitamin D production
in release subsequently is the GFR
starts to get the law 45 to 50 we don't
start seeing increases in parathyroid
hormone and actually the last alteration
we see is overt hyperphosphatemia that
occurs rather late in the progression of
CKD generally in CKD stage four or stage
five a lot of these earlier hormonal
changes the increase of fgf23 the
decrease of 125 vitamin D and the
increase of parathyroid hormone are
actually occurring to help us maintain
mural normal serum phosphate
concentrations I just I want to get to
the parathyroid hormone calcium access
here and as we know parathyroid hormone
is the principal calcium regulating
hormone and it controls calcium balance
by activating the receptor in the kidney
in bone increased calcium reabsorption
occurs in a thick ascending limb and
that distal convoluted tubule to kidney
it also increases the one L hydroxylase
activity in the proximal tubules and it
indirectly increases axial class bone
resorption in order to increase calcium
into the body the PT parathyroid gland
actually senses the decreases in calcium
by the calcium sensory receptor on the
glam surface and very small changes in
the serum calcium sends up stimulating a
parathyroid hormone this right here
better demonstrates the relationship
between ionized calcium and parathyroid
hormone secretion the graph the line to
the left is actually what we see in
normal individuals outward and I want to
note out that Gareth our lead hormone
secretion never goes down to zero we
have a constitutive production of PTH
and as the calcium drops their
production of Pete parathyroid hormone
increases and as calcium increases the
production of PTH and release decreases
we have the concept of the set point of
PTH which is the calcium concentration
in which you have fifty percent
inhibition of maximum parathyroid
hormone secretion pin patients with
renal disease and secondary
hyperparathyroidism as you can see by
the line to the right we get a shift in
this set point to the right and then it
takes a higher serum calcium in order to
inhibit parathyroid hormone
concentrations or pillitteri hormone
release again looking at parathyroid
hormone here is a regulator a fast
metabolism you again see is we have
increasing parathyroid hormone we do
affect phosphorus in a couple ways we
initially affect fasters because
increased parathyroid hormone will
actually increase bone resorption it
will cause a release of serum phosphorus
the parathyroid hormone does help to
enhance fast iturea by enhancing
phosphate excretion by the kidneys is
noted there we have fgf 20
three which is get is released by bone
and acts to stimulate facts Victoria but
in addition we have parathyroid hormone
that stimulates the 125 vitamin D it
helps to enhance phosphate absorption in
the GI tract so as you can see there's a
very complicated system of regulatory
and counselor utility hormones including
parathyroid hormone calcitriol at fgf-23
that tries to maintain normal phosphate
balance in terms of the factors that
contribute to the Secretariat
hyperparathyroidism again as I mentioned
we have decreased kidney function we get
an increase of fast versus an increase
of fgf23 and a decrease in calcitriol
that results in a decrease in our
calcium absorption in the GI tract those
factors actually affect the parathyroid
gland that we have a low calcium causing
an increase in parathyroid hormone
production but we also have a decrease
in the vitamin D expression and
decreases in both the vitamin D receptor
and the calcium receptor at the level of
the parathyroid gland so therefore takes
a higher serum calcium in order to
inhibit parathyroid hormone with time we
get a parathyroid gland hyperplasia her
which then continues with further
increase of parathyroid hormone
secretion and this feeds back to the
bone where we get increased on bone
resorption in terms of the absolute
regulation at the parathyroid gland
again as I mentioned parathyroid hormone
is constitutively released and we
basically have inhibitory factors we
have the calcium sensing receptor that
hacks to exhibit parathyroid hormone
release we have the vitamin D receptor
which also helps to inhibit parathyroid
hormone release and we also know that
fgf23 will combine with its receptor and
co-localize with clothes which also has
an inhibitory effect and parathyroid
hormone so most of the factors that we
have in terms of
regulating pth have to do with
inhibition of its production and release
if we look at what happens in the
evolution of CKD and hyperparathyroidism
we get progressive parathyroid hormone
hyperplasia initially with diffuse
hyperplasia you get a decrease in your
calcium sensing receptor your vitamin D
receptor and the receptor for fgf with
time you start forming nodules and as
these nodules start to form they become
monoclonal and they actually have a
marked decrease in the calcium sensing
receptor the vitamin D receptor and the
fgf receptor therefore is this disease
progresses this tissue themselves become
totally unresponsive to as regulatory
factors the calcium vitamin D and fgf23
and it's almost like cancer biology is
that you have unregulated growth of the
tissue as well as unregulated production
of parathyroid hormone so the question
is could we use parathyroid hydropower
thyroidism as a disease entity in and of
itself or is it a surrogate marker under
lock scoring other diseases and
pathologies and in nephrology this is
one of the biggest things that we
struggle with whether we use parathyroid
hormone as a marker or as a disease in
and of itself well in terms of
surrogates we do tend to use it as a
surrogate of bone disease and it is its
major factor on how we assess whether
patients have bone disease and in
particular the incidence of fractures we
also have been looking at it in terms of
surrogates of various outcomes of
patients such as hospitalizations
cardiovascular disease and mortality and
most of the epidemiological studies have
shown an association with high
parathyroid hormone concentrations with
poor patient outcome and mortality
there's multiple clinical manifestations
associated with primary
hyperparathyroidism
in the sense that absolute dated reasons
including the bone disease classically
osteoporosis cystica as well as
association with fractures the
development of kidney stones
hypophosphatemia increased production of
calcitriol even to the point of having
cardiovascular disease with hypertension
and ldh associated with
hyperparathyroidism in patients who have
normal kidney function what about in
secondary hyperparathyroidism in chronic
kidney disease and again there seems to
be associations with bone and or joint
pain the association's of fractures are
not that clear-cut clinically these
patients do develop a proximal myopathy
and reduce the spontaneous tendon
rupture growth retardation and children
there's clearly when the parathyroid
hormone levels get high we get extra
skeletal classifications council axis
because of the fibrosis in the bone
marrow that tends to make the anemia CNN
CKD worse there's evidence of
neurotoxicity pure itís is a major
problem as well as cardiomyopathy has
been associated with high QTH levels in
patients with chronic kidney disease so
it turns the secondary
hyperparathyroidism as a disease we
clearly have a lot of evidence and I'm
just showing you here a couple images of
patients this is a patient who presented
to dialysis with severe
hyperparathyroidism and as you could
look at you in the CT scan you can see
nafas calcification within his sinuses
the protrusion of the jaw and the loss
of peace you can see here on the skull
it's got the classic salt and pepper
characteristics we see with increased
bone resorption you can also notice the
calcification on the ears and auricular
calcification of the council be
deposited there and again if you look at
the upper jaw you can see spaces behind
between the teeth there as erosion of
the bone here is a classic ground tumor
that is seen in patients
hyperparathyroidism i looks very similar
to the same types of lesions to see with
multiple myeloma and finally we have the
syndrome
Cal Cecil axis this is the classic
Kelsey feel actors we've seen with
severe I prepare thyroidism where you
get basically occlusion of your small
distal vessels to ski me up and
eventually necrosis other factors we see
is this slide here is the auricular
calcification in the shoulder in the
upper left-hand corner you can see this
arterial where we have Max's medial
calcification within this artery here
very common these patients are a bit
different than what we see with
hypercholesterolemia and calcium plaques
in the cluster all whereas here you have
actual calcium laid down within the
medial aspect of the vessel another
patient here was extra calcification as
you can see up in your shoulder and
finally you can see the CT scan in the
lower right-hand corner obviously you
can see the ribs and the spine there and
that yellow is the captive bone or the
calcium but if you look at his coronary
arteries they appear basically the same
density is what we see in the skeleton
of this patient as I mentioned there is
association with parathyroid hormone and
outcomes that is shown here in patients
prior to dialysis you can see that
behind of the parathyroid hormone
concentration is there is an increased
risk of all-cause mortality this is
looking at dialysis patients again dr.
Martin showed you the range of 150 to
300 which was the k dokey range in some
of that was determined based on data
like this but you can see is the
parathyroid hormone level gets involved
three hundred micrograms per milliliter
you can see an increase in mortality
interestingly we also see an increase in
mortality with patients with very low
off their thyroid levels concentrations
this is probably due to malnutrition and
inflammation associated with these
patients so I want to just give a couple
cases to give you some flavor of how we
use pth and how difficult
it may be in its interpretation this
case here is a 42 year old
african-american male who did on
hemodialysis for 15 years with us AV
fistula he actually does nightly home
hemodialysis five times a week for seven
a half hours so he's someone who is
otherwise very well dialyzed and
actually does not need a lot of
medications because of them as you can
see news item if I hypertensive
medications I phosphate binder pair of
cows cause of vitamin D analog read
hyperparathyroidism as well as Senate
causa which is a calcium sensitive
pneumatic his physical exam is
essentially and remarkable showing here
are his labs I just want to point out is
calcium is relatively normal as facts
first actually it's not too bad for a
dialysis patient but there's a book even
above the 5.5 level the doctor Marisa
pointed out and as you can see if
thorough Sara's normal level is well
over 2,000 by the correct meaning the
one you can see these fairly well
dialyzed these ultrasound images are of
the neck maybe a little hard for you to
make out but you can see the image on
the Left shows a parathyroid nodule
lectures a parathyroid gland is markedly
enlarged normally you cannot see the
parathyroid glands now when you do an
ultrasound of the neck and to confirm
that it's pure thyroid in this image to
the right you can see the market
increased blood flow when the color
doppler is put into it diseased plants
tend to be very vascular well just to
give you an idea of how difficult is to
look at parathyroid hormone
concentrations and to put with dr.
Markham showed you earlier to real
patient kill you can see here are his
labs over a four-month period and I just
want to highlight the parathyroid
hormone again this is an intact back
side with an upper limit of normal 288
you can see that the values varied from
month to month between 1100 and
basically 2,100 with very little changes
in his calcium and phosphorus so again
the issue of having good PGH essays and
how
be translated into patients become
somewhat difficult when we take it to
individual patients the second case is a
76 year old Caucasian female with CKD
stings for from diabetes and
hypertension she said a couple long time
of fractures shown here are her
medication she's also on vitamin D as
well as kalfa trial with an active
vitamin D our blood pressure is
relatively normal she's a frail woman
but you know not too remarkable in terms
of the physical exam shown here are her
lab sighs you could see her credits 2.6
again putting her about a stage for CKD
near parathyroid hormone levels 173
clearly elevated from normal but if she
was a CKD stage 5 that would be in the
target range however even to that
guidelines it back devices gave you
earlier this would be high because CKD
stage 4 we felt she had levels less than
110 our vitamin D levels a little low or
alkaline phosphatase is a little bit
elevated calcium within range and
phosphorus within range and one would
predict based on his profile that she
would have hyperparathyroidism with
hyperparathyroidism however if we do a
bone biopsy on who is shown here this is
really a biopsy of low bone turnover as
you look along the bone trabeculae there
you see absolutely no cellular activity
no evidence of resorption or formation
and the reddish color area is that of a
sterling and that is rather minimal and
there's no evidence of marrow fibrosis
or anything else so in fact she does not
have hyperparathyroidism but he was
rather low turnover what we would call
road turnover a dynamic bone disease if
you would not want to address as we
treat her for hyperparathyroidism in
spite of what her laboratory showed so
our clinical practice really has been to
use the parathyroid hormone and as
and indicator of bone disease again dr.
Martin went over this earlier giving you
the k dokey que digo guidelines of pth
again we focused mostly on stage 5 i
will say that these guidelines were
developed there was not a whole lot of
evidence necessarily to support them
this is looking at parathyroid hormone
concentrations from the diocese outcomes
practice group that gives all dialysis
patients and as you can see with time
we've actually increased our parathyroid
hormone concentrations for 2,000 attack
at 2 2013 as we've liberalized the area
of having pth levels up to nine times
the upper limit of normal again we don't
have any real good data saying whether
this is good beneficial for the patients
or that I just want to go into how we
really look at bone disease and that's
by bone biopsies in the center there you
can see a normal bone is normal to
affect you I you look at it you do have
an area of bone resorption as well as
there is a bone formation and hastily in
the upper left hand corner is a classic
picture of osteomalacia where you have a
large degree of unrealized bone and you
may have at both active bone resorption
information going on if the lower left
is the a dynamical similar to the
patient I showed you where there's
absolutely no bone cell activity and
very little a steely in the lower right
hand corner is that about the other side
will sophistic I which is the classic
lesion all type of filler thyroidism you
see a lot of bone resorption going on as
well as actually being laid down and
above that is something we've turned
next year either faster dystrophy or a
mixed lesion we have both osteomalacia
or lack of mineralization as well as
high turnover bone disease well que digo
is actually come out with a better way a
different way to classify what we call
the TMD system where we look at turnover
mineralization and volume and this is to
better objectify or
biopsy's opposed to quality measures in
turn over to be the high normal or null
mineralization normal or abnormal and
volume either hi normal and low if we
look at the biopsies we had earlier if
you look at in a dynamic bone here you
can see this one could be either low
turnover abnormal mineralization because
there's no mineralization in normal
volume the mix region has high turnover
abnormal mineralization because there's
too much actually being laid down the
wrapping their lives in low volume in
the I see is red roses cystica would be
a high turnover again abnormal
mineralization the bone volume is
actually increased while we are using
this Dell class size we look at the
classic vacation system on what patients
have been ctd hemodialysis and
peritoneal dialysis you can see about
two-thirds of the hemodialysis patients
have evidence of hyperparathyroidism
where is a much larger percentage of
patients with CKD and doing peritoneal
dialysis that tend to have a lower bone
turnover if we look at again the use of
parathyroid hormone to predict bone
formation rate as you can see here the
green area is the normal bone formation
rate it's very difficult that
parathyroid hormone has been very
helpful in identifying patients with
either low or high bone turnover there's
many confounders for the measurement of
PTH such as the dynamic metabolic state
through an acidosis the vitamin D status
is back to mark mission mention
fragments oxidation the effect of fgf23
calcium phosphorus magnesium and
dialysis is well as specific therapy for
parathyroid isms such as vitamin d
analogs and telematics as well as there
is a circadian rhythm for the secretion
of PTH in terms of another study trying
to use pth I to predict bone disease
again you can see that acura fibrosis is
associated with very high pth levels but
you can also see there's a lot of
overlap when you go to the very low bone
turnover where a get it tends to be low
so you could have significantly high p
th in the ranges of patients with a
steel Titus fibrosis I just want to wrap
up here on a project that we've been
involved in that was just published
earlier this year and was a que digo
project where we had some 500 patients
biopsies as well as parathyroid hormone
concentrations we had parathyroid the
intact parathyroid hormone concentration
we also had a parathyroid hormone
concentration that was by the old system
when the biopsy was obtained some 10 or
15 years ago as well as a whole if the
body of the whole 12 84 and if you look
here in terms of the correlations there
is a fairly good correlation with the
intact pth and the whole assay of 0.9 26
however the correlation between the
originally measured in tact in the
subsequently measured in tact was not
that good nor was it with the original
measured in tact and the OL biopsy if we
wanted to use pth again by these
different assays to discriminate low
from normal to high bone turnover again
looking at populations it does look like
we get a statistical significant
difference between long normal and high
using either the intact or the whole as
well as using both specific alkaline
phosphatase or purely or peptides but
again there's a lot of overlap as I
showed you before if we really wanted to
discriminate we did do receiver
operators curves and areas of the curves
trying to discriminate bone turnover by
seven biochemistry this is looking at
low verse normal or high verse novel and
numbers may be hard but you really want
to have an area under the curve
at least point 72.8 to be somewhat
helpful point seven is just minimal and
as you see here only bone specific
output phosphatase to discriminate low
from normal back normal bone turnover
was helpful in at a point seven six with
a cut-off being either above or below
33.1 units per liter all the other
biochemical measurements in terms of
differentiating loan from normal or
normal and high were actually not
helpful shown here is just looking at
novus mad low or high vers changhai in
at least here when we looked at all the
parathyroid hormone essays and the bone
specific alkaline phosphatase we do get
an area under the curve at least point
seven however to really according to
most statisticians to be helpful you
really would like to see this at point
is in the combination of PTH with both
specific alkaline phosphatase do not
necessarily help again looking at this
project looking at both specificity
different sensitivity you can see that
our positive predictive values by using
either the k dokey guideline which is
150 to 300 or the K deagle guideline
which is up to nine times the upper
limit of normal is not very robust
except for the negative predictive value
differentiating high 49 high bone at
turnover in this patient population so I
thank you for your attention and I hope
you appreciate some of the difficulties
that without dealing with it using a
parathyroid hormone to help us assess
our patients thank you both dr. Martin
and dr. Sprague for any Nessus and from
the informative presentation it's time
for our Q&A now I'm just going to remind
our audience they have a question click
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window type in your
question and we'll try to
to as many as we can we do have one
question and our cute already we have a
question from an audience member what
length of time of having
hyperparathyroidism does it take for the
calcification of the shoulder the photo
you showed how long would a patient have
to have hyperthyroidism for that to
occur I the patient who had the couch
the hump above his shoulder was actually
a relatively young guy he was in his 30s
and he had renal failure for about 10-12
years his pth levels were up in the
2000s not very well controlled the one
that had the calcification was in the
shoulder was a bit older it was also
about 10 to 15 years on dialysis again
with t th levels in the two to three
thousand range these patients also
tended to have relatively poorly
controlled serum phosphate the one that
had the calcification above his shoulder
actually also is hyper calcium it but I
think you're talking about you know
clearly more than six to ten years of
that well controlled disease thank you
for that answer I'm just going to check
our cue to see if we have any more
incoming questions I don't see any and
we are just about out of time I would
like to once again thank dr. Martin and
dr. Sprague for teaming up for this
presentation do any of you have any
final comments through our audience
I think we don't really have to at the
present time it's them I hope what we've
shown is them it's a difficult area I
had to to put the lab work and the
clinical work together and it's a the
variability in the assays continues to
be a problem and hopefully I will be
able to continue to work on that and
bring it to some kind of formal
resolution hopefully in the not too
distant future thank you so much once
again I'd like to thank dr. Sprague and
dr. Martin and of course thank our
sponsor siemens healthcare diagnostics
are making today's educational webcast
possible before we sign off I want to
let everybody know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through May of 2016 attendees for today
will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when that webcast is
available for replay and we would invite
you to please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event once again thank you
to dr. Martin and dr. Sprague our
sponsor siemens healthcare we hope to
see you again thank you for joining us
thank you thank you